if you want to talk about symbols of the
Democrat Party there was a clip
absolutely devastating from John
fetterman out on the trail just a couple
of days ago campaigning is a strong wind
blew the American flags away
areas he's talking and then they just
all all the American flags tumble down
right before this guy and he doesn't
even he's not even aware of it
I guess he didn't hear it or he wasn't
paying attempts right behind him it was
just
it was a perfect symbol okay and I'm a
big believer in Providence I'm a very
big believer in Providence I think as my
friend Father George Rottler points at
it's a wicked generation that looks for
signs and wonders but it's a stupid
generation that ignores signs and
wonders
and the world is just Rife with symbols
and that's a pretty clear one
what exactly that symbol or Omen
portends that remains to be seen
but it certainly is not a good look for
fetterman that's very true you just we
just have this sense
okay and I think it's people in the
center and people even on the center
left who are looking at the Democrats
who say you know these people
they don't seem to like us
they don't seem to like us they don't
seem to like the country they don't seem
to be very good at governing the country
the country does not seem to be doing
well under their Rule and so then the
one issue that they they focused on in
2022
where they weren't either complete
losers in their policy and or uh torn
between their radical base and what the
American people want which are in
contradiction with one another so the
one issue they've focused on that they
thought was going to take them across
the Finish Line was abortion
Robbie Wade gets overturned by Dobbs
okay we're gonna rally all those women
we're gonna campaign to kill the babies
and this is about how well it's going
bado O'Rourke just released this this
little insta real or Tick Tock or
whatever the hell it was uh in his final
push on his doomed campaign
it's a woman dancing says a Texas woman
who just wants rights and she's dancing
slowly and then
the creepiest dude you've ever seen in
your whole life Beto O'Rourke wearing
the one blue shirt that he owns wearing
skinny jeans like some hipster sexually
ambiguous
sophomore in college creeping up on a
girl at a party is a pro-choice governor
who's ready to fight for her and he's
just dancing slowly like it should have
been released on
on Halloween so
and I don't mean just to pick on Beto
O'Rourke though it is easy to do
Beto O'Rourke is every male feminist and
every male feminist is super duper
creepy
super creepy super weird the abortion
issue was always a loser for the
Democrats it's a even bigger loser when
it's men campaigning there's something
really creepy about hey I mean I'm gonna
fight really really hard to make sure
that if women get pregnant we can kill
the kid and I don't have to worry about
it
[Music]
hey you want to watch me skateboard lady
like no get out of here you know spray
bear mace in his face or something get
out of here I don't get away from me man
stop creeping up on me it's very sad to
think how far Beto O'Rourke has fallen
he was a an unremarkable member of
Congress then he decides that he's going
to run for Senate
so he runs for Senate in Texas and loses
and then he runs for president because
that's what happens when you lose a
senate race then you can run for
president and he had all the backing he
had all the backing of the liberal
establishment they loved this guy there
was a Vanity Fair spread
this big Vanity Fair spread of Beto and
it was on the cover he said I was built
for this I was made to be in this fight
it's all about me and I knew that was
the kiss of death
because I knew at that point Beto is
just a completely contrived thing
and this is why the libs are losing
right now and why they can't make sense
of why they're losing because they're
believing their own press releases okay
and this is some of the best advice my
mother ever gave me when I was a kid I
was a little kid and I did really well
on the test and I don't know I was uh
top of my class or something I got a
swell head and she said you know Michael
don't believe your own press releases
and the Democrats have believed their
own press releases and they've really
convinced themselves I think a lot of
them have convinced themselves they
really are the voice of the people the
Democrat the Republicans really do pose
an existential threat they have Democrat
the Republicans really are the Nazis the
Democrats are the only four standing in
the way of the Nazis it's the people
understand this they see it and it's
just not true and people are laughing at
them and they're laughing the people are
laughing at the New York Times over
Russia Russia Russia and the people are
laughing at the Southern Poverty Law
Center over the you know Pearl clutching
at the observation that men are not
women and women are not men and we
shouldn't chop each other's genitals off
to think otherwise and we we shouldn't
trans the kids and and people like
borders and people like a good economy
and the Democrats they've just they're
so locked in their own Echo chamber and
they have that Echo chamber because they
have virtually all the power in the
country the people I think still have
some say in it and if the if the people
get a little
if the people assert their rights and if
the people assert
their rights at the polls and they
express what they want for their country
you're going to have to see the
Democrats make a choice here the liberal
establishment will have to either give
up some power give up some of what it
wants to do or clamp down twice as hard
and become more overtly authoritarian
this is what you see when Ron clay and
the white house chief of staff comes out
and he says one last warning don't do
this people one I'm giving you one last
warning that's not just a warning about
the Republic what the Republicans will
do in power it's a warning about what
the liberal establishment will do
if the people vote for their opponents
now it is music Monday so the rest of
the show continues on we've got a a
great song I am told this was uh chosen
by associate producer Jacob
he's a rap mogul
apparently it's a conservative rap song
I know I did I didn't wanna I know but
hey he he says it's really really great
so we'll check it out on music Monday
I'll be chatting with you over at the
member block if you're not already a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]